[Applaudissements]
maintenant je me demande d'accueillir le
député de la haute-savoie secrétaire
général des républicains bernard acoyer
[Applaudissements]
chers amis c'est un bonheur de vous voir
aussi nombreux
ici autour de notre candidat françois
fillon
cet amateur de vous voir autour de ces
drapeaux dans cette ville de lyon qui
restera dans notre coeur et dans notre
histoire toujours la capitale de la
résistance pour que vive la france et ce
soir c'est encore un combat pour la
france
un combat pour une certaine idée de la
france qui nous rassemble de gaulle
disait il faut vouloir que la france
existe car cela n'ira jamais plus de
soin et bien cette volonté pour que vive
la france
il y à un homme qu'il incarne
aujourd'hui il y à un homme qui la porte
cet homme c'est françois fillon parce
qu'il a établi un diagnostic lucide de
notre pays parce qu'il a bâti avec des
milliers de français un projet réaliste
et ambitieux parce qu'il disposera d'une
majorité solide et cohérente
françois fillon est le seul qui peut
s'engager à redresser la situation
nationale et sauver la france du chaos
menaçant au terme du pitoyable quintilla
de françois hollande
[Musique]
ce diagnostic est le constat de vérité
de l'état de la france
cinq ans de renoncement cinq ans de
hausse du chômage et de la dette cinq
ans de matraquage fiscal cinq ans
d'effacement de la voix de la france en
europe et dans ce monde dangereux
monsieur hollande monsieur macron parce
que vous êtes les mêmes qu'avez-vous
fait contre le chômage
qu'avez vous fait pour le pouvoir
d'achat
qu'avez vous fait pour notre
compétitivité économique
qu'avez vous fait pour notre agriculture
pour notre industrie
vous avez tous fait les familles
au point que la seule courbe que vous
soyez parvenu à inverser chez celles de
la natalité
une catastrophe pour l'avenir de la
france et pour notre pacte social fondé
sur la solidarité entre les générations
vous avez laisser bafouer l'autorité
vous avez laissé grandir la sécurité
dans nos quartiers dans nos campagnes
laisser monter l'immigration clandestine
et les communautarismes qui menace la
cohésion nationale où est la france
quand la russie et les etats unis se
disputent seul le sort de la syrie et de
la paix dans le monde
où est la france quand le totalitarisme
islamiste se répand partout jusque dans
nos villes et nos villages
chers amis c'est parce qu'il est le seul
à avoir fondé son programme sur ce
diagnostic lucide que françois fillon et
son projet portent nos espérances oui
notre beau pays a besoin de revenir sur
quatre décennies au cours desquelles il
a oublié les fondements qui ont bâti
notre nation
la place de l'autorité celle de
l'éducation et de la formation
la place du travail du mérite et de
l'excellence
l'exigence du contrôle des flux
migratoires
sigean ce de la sécurité oui nous nous
sommes laissé submerger par une
idéologie fait des collectivistes
égalitariste émollient et d'une bien
pensants sont propagées par des pseudos
intellectuels ou des penseurs
autoproclamé il n'était rien d'autre que
des soixante huitards reconverti en bo
bo bobo droits de l'hommistes héritiers
de cette culture marxiste de salon
poison du 20e siècle
toujours plus de dépenses publiques et
donc toujours plus d'impôts de taxes de
charges toujours plus de contraintes
administratives et donc moins de liberté
moins de compétitivité et moins
d'emplois productifs créateurs de
richesse toujours plus de subventions
pour nourrir une chape aux litiges et de
collectivités dans les collectivités
locales et des associations relais
politiques qui écrase nos idées nos
projets et condamne notre avenir pour
sauver notre économie nos entreprises
nos services publics régaliens et notre
pacte social
la france a besoin de mesures fortes à
la tête de la région rhône alpes de la
région rhône alpes auvergne
laurent wauquiez a déjà démontré que
c'était possible et je suis content de
le lui dire
le jour de son anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
demain avec françois fillon c'est la
france il retrouvera l'espérance il est
le seul à pouvoir la promettre à nos
compatriotes légitimement inquiets parce
qu'il sera le seul à pouvoir disposer
d'une majorité à l'assemblée nationale
nos 577 candidats d'union des
républicains et de l'idée est de lui d y
sont prêts ils sont en campagne derrière
françois fillon faire ami ouvrons
ensemble les yeux de nos compatriotes
sur les aventures sans retour sur des
aventures mortel auquel voudrait les
condamner l'extrême droite de marine le
pen et l'extrême-gauche repeint aux
couleurs bobos de jean-luc mélenchon
ouvrons les yeux on voyait le jeu sur
l'escroquerie la tromperie sur la
marchandise d'un maquereau qui cache de
plus en plus mal
le socialisme qui l'habite qui l'a
conduit des allées dorées de la haute
administration à la financiarisation de
l'économie et au calamiteux pouvoir
hollandais chers amis
et il nous reste onze jours pour lever
la confusion qui occulte la campagne et
le débat démocratique crucial de cette
présidentielle
oui onze jours pour faire gagner la
france
faire gagner françois fillon nous le
ferons ensemble pour que vive la france
[Applaudissements]